And joining us now White House
press secretary Jen Kawasaki Jen
welcome back to Fox News Sunday
thank you Chris.
Thanks for having me on this
morning President Biden has
taken to asking critics of his
COVID relief bill what would you
call it the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office says
that more than one third
of the total bill $700 billion
would not be spent this year
but would be spent between 2022
and 20202031 so how does that
qualify as COVID relief well
first Chris the focus
of the package is getting direct
checks to the American people
getting vaccines in the arms
of Americans and ensuring that
people who need help at this
very difficult time can get it
but people also have to plan
schools have to plan to reopen
they need to do budgetary
planning over
the course of years businesses
need to do that as well.
So this packages are meant
to of course, provide immediate
Direct Relief but also provide
a bridge to help us all get
through this crisis.
But let's take one specific area
that you just mentioned schools
the bill would give $170 billion
to schools from elementary
through college but the CBO
projects that 95% of that money
again won't be spent this year
but will be spent from 2022
through 2028 and let me drill
down even further $480 million
of the COVID relief bill
according to the CBO would go
to the Arts humanities museums,
libraries again what does that
have to do with emergency COVID
relief and getting kids back
into school this year Well first
of all 90% of this package goes
to address the twin crises
we're facing right now Chris
which is getting the pandemic
under control and helping
the American people go back
to work helping them get
the relief they need to get
through this period of time
schools are like businesses
Chris they need to budgetary
plan over a period of time.
Some have to front load changes,
whether it's to their facilities
or ensuring that if they have
to hire additional teachers
or bus or bus drivers at this
point, we're talking about
to ensure that we're not saying
that well they have to plan over
the period of time I'm sure I
don't want my kids to be going
to school where they have
to fire teachers next year
or won't have to be able to do
the facilities a facility
upgrades I should say necessary
in order to ensure they're going
to school safely that's exactly
what is included in this
package.
Let me turn to another subject
about the bill now that
the Senate parliamentarian has
ruled that the $15 minimum wage
does not qualify under
the budget rules some Senate
Democrats are talking about
either using tax incentives
or tax penalties to get
corporations and small
businesses to go there as part
of the COVID relief bill does
the president support that.
Well I think you're referring
to Senator Sanders proposal
Chris and we have not yet
reviewed that proposal
but the Senate the president
supports exactly what Senator
Sanders does, which is
increasing the minimum wage
for the American people
for workers who are just trying
to make ends meet and he thinks
that's long overdue.
We're going to have to spend
the next several days or even
weeks figuring out what the best
path for it is
but he's committed to doing that
you also had a busy week
on foreign policy and I want
to talk about that during
the campaign candidate Biden
said that he promised to crack
down on Saudi Arabia
for the murder of Jamal
Khashoggi here he is we were
going to in fact, make them pay
the price and make them.
In fact, the pariah that they
are there's very little social
redeeming value
of in the present government
in Saudi Arabia and on Friday US
intelligence agencies released
this report we assess that Saudi
Arabia's crown Prince Mohammed
bin Sandmann approved
an operation in Istanbul, Turkey
to capture or kill Saudi
journalist Jamal Khashoggi
a couple of questions.
Does the president still believe
as he did back in November
of 2019 that the crown Prince
was personally responsible
personally ordered the murder
of Jamal Khashoggi and if he
does why didn't he move to act
against MBBS personally well
the president believes this was
a horrific crime and what we saw
outlined in the unclassified
report released as you
referenced Chris is confirmation
of the details of this crime
some that we've known for some
time and the president put what
was an advocate for releasing
that and abiding by our legal
obligations let me be very clear
though we we took specific
actions on Friday our objective
is to recalibrate
our relationship we've already
taken steps to
do that make sure it's not
a continuation of the last four
years and prevent the horrific
act that happens to our two
journalist Jamal Khashoggi from
ever happening again that's why
we put sanctions through
the Treasury Department
on the deputy head
of the intelligence Department
why are we under the Magnitsky
Act designated the Saudi
intelligence forces why
we've taken very specific steps
Chris to make sure we're sending
a clear message to the world.
And that's what we announced
on Friday but but it
isn't a clear message in 2019
the president in a Democratic
debate said that he believed
that NBC'S the crown Prince
personally ordered the murder
of Khashoggi that's what his
intelligence A report says,
I'm asking you now does he
personally believe that that
MBBS ordered the assassination
of Khashoggi and if he does why
not penalize him sanctions
a bunch of other people.
He doesn't sanction the crown
Prince well first let me be
clear that behind the scenes
there are a range of diplomatic
conversations that make
absolutely clear to the Saudis
and to others around the world
that this is going to be
a different kind of relationship
and our actions make that
absolutely clear as well Chris
historically though as you well
know you've been covering these
issues for some time the United
States has not historically
sanctioned the leaders
of countries where we have
diplomatic relations or even
some where we don't have
diplomatic relations we
understand that's a bar some are
holding this
to but our objective here from
the government from the Biden
administration is preventing
this
from ever happening again I
should also note we also
announced the shoghi rule which
gives power to the Secretary
of State to be able
to to prevent foreigners who
have to have shown that they are
going to threaten dissidents
or journalists from traveling
on a visa to the United States.
This is a global issue and one
we're going to be clear
in sending a message about both
privately and publicly Chris
I'm running out of time
and I've got a couple
of questions I need to ask you
the president also ordered
a military strike in Eastern
Syria this week against Iranian
backed militias is he sending
a message that there is a link
between an Iran nuclear deal
and Iran's activities
in the region that there
can't be an agreement there
can't be successful diplomacy
at the same time that Iranian
backed forces are attacking us
personnel Christie sending
an unambiguous message that
he's going to protect our men
and women serving
and our coalition forces.
And that's exactly what he did
with this strike in terms
of the Iranian nuclear deal we
believe that the best path is
a diplomatic path forward.
We want to prevent Iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
that's in our national interest
that's in the global national
interest where that sits now
as we're weighting the Europeans
are waiting to hear back from
the Iranians on whether they
will sit at the table and have
that discussion but the strike
this week was specifically about
responding to threats
and attacks that were
threatening our troops
and our men and women serving
overseas the president or rather
the Biden administration this
week reopened a migrant facility
for children that was used under
President Trump and that
unleashed a storm of criticism
as you know Congresswoman
Alexandria cosio Cortez tweeted
this is not OK never has been OK
never
will be OK no matter
the administration or party now
you have to distinguish between
what you are doing and what
the Trump administration is
doing I'm asking you a different
question though isn't the Biden
administration contributing
to this crisis by reversing
the Trump policy which called
for immediately returning
migrant children who crossed
the country unaccompanied
children who crossed the border
by themselves and their border
patrol officials are saying that
you are creating a surge
and that by May we could see
a bigger surge than we saw
during the worst moments
of the 2019 crisis on the border
well Chris the vast majority
of families and adults are
turned away at the border.
This is not the time to come
and we have been very clear
about that.
But our approach from the Biden
administration is that we think
the most humane step we can take
here is to have these children
unaccompanied kids under 18 not
not send them back to take
a treacherous path forward this
is a difficult choice
but that's one that we felt was
the right one the most humane
one because these are kids
they're fleeing prosecution
they're fleeing difficult
circumstances in their country
and our objective is to treat
them humanely and to keep them
safe and the reason I should say
that we opened this facility is
because of COVID Chris as you
know and that's why it's open
because we want to keep these
kids safe,
including at a time where
we're facing a pandemic
but aren't you by changing
the policy aren't you
encouraging some of these young
people to come which means
you're going to have a bigger
crisis on the border well Chris
we've been unambiguous and very
big and clear in the region.
This is not the time Tacoma.
And this is the difficult choice
for everyone but as a mother,
as a parent I'm not going
to support not nor would
the president sending kids under
18 some of the age of 11, 12,
13 back on a treacherous trip
across the border to face
persecution and difficult
circumstances in their country
these kids are coming alone
and this is the choice
we've made because we feel
it's humane and we feel safe
the vast majority of any family
that's coming together any
adults that's coming are turned
away at the border because we
have not had time to put
in place comprehensive
immigration policies yet at this
point in time finally when will
the White House pull
the nomination of Neera Tanden
to be the budget director well
Chris we remain committed
to fighting our hearts out
for Neera Tanden we believe she
is the right person
she's qualified experienced
to lead the
budget Department she brings
unique experience as somebody
who's lived through benefitting
from a number of these programs
and she's worked on these issues
for decades across the aisle
so we're going to keep fighting
for it we knew that some
of these fights would be
difficult and this is certainly
one of them.
But she's going to have a number
of continued engagements.
This week and we are certainly
hopeful we can get it across
the finish line Jen there was
lots to talk to you about you
guys made a lot of news this
week.
Thank you.
Thanks for joining us today
always good to talk to you too.